-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We're so happy to be
with you tonight
and, now, we're going
to get to the news.
Eleven Democratic Senators
sent a letter
to President Biden yesterday,
calling on him to explore
options to lower gas prices,
which has to be so aggravating,
for a guy who's been hawking
Amtrak for 40 years.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Biden ] Oh,
are gas prices too high?
God, I wish I had
an idea for you.
[ Laughter ]
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
filed paperwork yesterday
to run for reelection in 2022,
which, in Florida,
is just finishing the maze
on the back page of Highlights.
[ Laughter ]
The writer who wrote that is
from Florida.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I don't want anyone to think
that it's just like us global --
whatever, coastal elites.
Global elites.
[ Laughter ]
Republican Representative
Paul Gosar on Sunday
tweeted a digitally editade --
edited, excuse me --
animé-style video
that appeared to show him
attacking Congresswoman
Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez
and President Joe Biden.
You edited yourself
into an animé cartoon?
[ Laughter ]
You're like that kid
in elementary school
who insists he knows kung fu,
but legally isn't allowed
to show you.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"My hands are registered
with the FBI, so..."
[ Laughter ]
Amazon founder Jeff Bezos
jokingly threatened
actor Leonardo DiCaprio
yesterday on Twitter
after a video surfaced
showing DiCaprio talking
with Bezos' girlfriend
at a gala.
What a scandal!
DiCaprio was talking to a woman
over the age of 30?!
[ Laughter and oohs ]
West Virginia
Senator Joe Manchin
is reportedly in talks
for a book deal.
Well, technically, someone else
will write the book,
then, he'll cut out
all the good parts.
[ Laughter and ohs ]
And that's budget comedy.
[ Laughter ]
Ooh, you came from budget comedy
and here it is.
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview,
New York Mayor-elect Eric Adams
suggested that cryptocurrency
should be taught in schools.
Oh, no, are we going to end up
missing this guy?
[ Laughter ]
France's Catholic Church
announced yesterday
that it would financially
compensate sex abuse victims
by selling assets
or taking on loans,
which explains this new listing
on Zillow.
[ Laughter and oohs ]
[ Cheering ]
Looks very nice.
According to a new report,
a 39,000-ton pile
of unsold clothes
from fast fashion retailers
has accumulated
in the Chilean desert.
Now, all they have to do is
build four walls around it
and throw up a sign.
[ Laughter and applause ]
According --
According to a new study,
going to bed too early
or too late may disrupt
the body's natural rhythm
and increase the risk
of cardiovascular disease.
So, just to be safe, let's all
randomly change our clocks
twice a year for no reason.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Nike has filed for trademarks
for a new line
of virtual clothing.
It'll be the first
Nike clothing line
made entirely
by virtual children.
[ Laughter and ohs ]
Now...
...when you guys didn't take
to the T.J.Maxx joke,
I had a feeling --
[ Laughter ]
I had a feeling this one was
going to be pretty bumpy, and...
[ Laughter ]
...called it.
And, finally, former
New York Governor Andrew Cuomo
over the weekend wished his dog
Captain a happy fourth birthday
in a post on social media.
Unfortunately, Captain
unfollowed him a long time ago.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody!